Sam yeah what's a Deena's so much I'll
be Bobby with Dean we're gonna watch the
supernatural season 2 bloopers gag reel
at a pad 3 on we do weekly Q&A s and we
do TV show reaction stream along for
several shows one of those being
supernatural we don't do anything else
all the time
it has reaction highlights included
started from season two we're on season
three right now we do stream along for
many shows those are Cobra Kai season
two haunting a hill house season one
Gotham aid 2 season 3 right now stranger
things season three agents of shield we
have the option for reaction highlights
for several shows as well as the stream
along for them and those are attack on
Titan Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood
my hero academia covered the movie to
Death Note Code Geass one punch man
hunter x hunter yeah that's it
supernatural two
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
apocalypse padalecki I'm just like
farting up a storm or somebody else in
the car
[Laughter]
who's going living the dream what can I
get for two beers please
- Pinot Grigio ji OH
[Laughter]
make his voice a little deeper talking
lower register 130 it sounds like every
time you mess up like to stand up and
sit back down
oh I'm so sorry yeah you play with the
guns
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
today's your lucky day kid
can she not see [ __ ] the contacts are
rough comers gotta be wanting to sing
about you let's just
oh thanks
you may know me from the award-winning
series I really can't you think okay
that was a big old goddess minute
[Music]
I feel like I understand the show so
much better now that I've seen this yeah
total it really fills in a lot of the
gaps other scenes that I can recall here
that like very serious moments and very
serious scenes in the show and then to
see how like loose they are while
filming in between filming I always
imagine actors just in like such serious
modes in between takes and all that you
know like just really feeling the
intensity the same either really
believable great or super pretentious
it's one of the 2d action underneath so
it's cool to see how loose they are yeah
and how much fun they're actually having
because a lot of supernatural requires
them to take so many situations with the
utmost seriousness they actually do seem
to have more of a brotherly dynamic more
than they do in the gym yeah and that's
been their really playful with each
other very very playful with each other
and it makes you wonder if that could
ever be a part of the show
they have like some crude humor back and
forth to when Jared Padalecki he's just
like farting up a storm in the car
smacking him on the ass Mack him on the
buns man it's also the way they banter
with one another which is kind of
relieving it makes sense why the show's
been able to go on for so long you know
I didn't know if it was one of those
things of you know they played brothers
and they're very close on camera that
she hated each other like I'm sure they
have days where they have tension after
working together for over a decade but
still he not to have that kind of
brotherly dynamics overly all by the
time you hit agreed season two it's
pretty great you need that I've heard it
said that they are very close and there
is like a family vibe on it it reminds
me like there are easy comparisons to
draw to Buffy but oddly though the one
that speaks to me the most is the fact
that like when Buffy was on the air
there were such dedicated fans and also
like and I'm sure there was some
friction in there too but there was a
tight cast and there was a tight cast
and fan community kind of vibe going on
and I think Supernatural really has that
too and I've heard it said just by folks
who follow the show very closely they
are
super close and through something like
this that does come out and that does
become a parent and yeah it does seem
like heart up I mean you know you got
the ideas and you've got the creators
behind the camera like Eric Kripke and
Kim manners and those guys who are
putting the stamps on the creative
aspect of the show but it's Kim Mathers
by the way Kim Mathers it's right we
almost didn't have supernatural of if
she and Marshall yeah yeah supernaturals
one of my favorite shows to watch
everybody so much fun yeah the first was
like six to eight episodes worried the
pylorus one was gripped by Louise
incredible and then there's a few
episodes now it's just consistently like
the show I look forward to the most
every week just to watch yeah yeah yeah
and then we covered I don't like to
watch too many bloopers I get pulled out
from the intensity of the show cuz that
I'm aware of what that's like one thing
to watch bloopers for friends yeah
because it's already a funny show the
point is like oh yeah but this you know
especially when you're seeing so many
serious scenes I don't want to get
pulled out of a serious scene thinking
about what it's a comedy right yeah
exactly like what were they really like
on set yeah but people have been asking
us for a long time to check this I
figured might as well write I feel like
you know you spend a while you finish
the season you get a little distance
from it then you watch the blue yes
exactly yeah or I like to watch the
bloopers before I watch this definitely
really really great the tension early
that it's comfortable lighting is it
spoiled or are they just teasing us or
our scene come was that just an ad-lib
that's not even gonna appear in the
episode are they exactly
just improv you could have shown this if
someone hasn't seen season two none of
it would have been ruined no the only
thing you would have spoiled
theoretically is just faces of people
who might show up yeah exactly yeah you
know he was not in any of this sterling
K Brown I know apparently he didn't ever
break or be funny not mess around oh
he's a certainly Kate brown there's no
serious guy in the world
even in the comedy movies oh yeah super
serious alright guys well we love it if
you would subscribe her the real rejects
click that notification bell join our
reject army become a reject the night
gets reject an eyes 1 million patronage
ick
let's give a patron the day shout out to
a lovely lady Albay hell Bay and
Arkansas's Arkansas they have to have
done like a bunch of cases in Arkansas
on the show right guys I might tell you
about Albie
you know her personality is like it's
kind of like Rory from Gilmore Girls
that kind of a little bit of clarice
starling as in attracted to cannibal or
you know just psychotic serial killers a
hint of Penelope Garcia from Criminal
Minds yeah that goes in line with the
whole attracted to dangerous individuals
she's close with her mom yeah definitely
loves pop culture references but she can
be indecisive she can be very quiet or
shy but when you get to know her though
she's so taut she's very talkative when
you get to know her yeah she's very
practical smart lady he's smart curious
information driven that's one thing I
love about it I feel like she's I empath
yeah definitely definitely and also
protective you know like friends and
loved ones
yeah she's got like a you know nurturing
vibe we came up with all that just from
getting to know her over the course
thinking about eating in our patreon
page the aura of Elle